สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 3 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
เมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 2 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 4
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
7 โมง
7 โมงกี่นาที
ค่ะ
7:11 นวันนี้ครูฟัดตื่นเร็วมากๆนะคะ
ครูฟ้าตื่นตั้งแต่ตี 3 แล้วค่ะ
ตอนนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่ประเทศ
ไทยใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ย
อยู่ออสเตรเลีย
อยู่ที่บ้านแล้ว
เขาเรียกอะไรนะเปลี่ยนใช่ไหมเปลี่ยนที่
นอนนอนไม่โอเคหรอคะก็เลยตื่นตั้งแต่
ตี 3
ไม่ใช่ค่ะฟ้าเปลี่ยนที่นอนด้วยแล้วก็หนาว
ด้วยนะคะ
เท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้าอากาศกี่องศาเซลเซียส 7
โอ้โหมีลมไหมมีลมไหม
มีลมด้วยแล้วกล้วยไม้
ใส่ถุงมือไหม
ถุงมือ
ถุงมือไง
ซื้อได้นะคะครูฟ้าเขามี Supermarket น่า
จะมีขาย
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าอยู่ที่ออสเตรเลียตอนนี้
เนี่ยครูฟ้าอยู่ที่บ้านใช่ไหม
ใช่แล้ว
แล้วที่บ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีๆเขาเรียกอะไร
อ่ะมีพื้นที่ไหมแบบนี้
แล้วก็เป็นประตูใช่ไหม
แบบนี้หรือว่ามีบ้านแล้วก็มีบ้านมีบ้านมี
บ้านติดกัน
หรอแบบ a หรอครูฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะใช่ๆ
เออใช่ๆ
อ๋อโอเคมีรั้วนิดนึงไหม
มีรั้วนิดหน่อย
หรือแค่นี้นะอาจจะไม่ได้ใหญ่มากใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วตอนนี้ก็จะเป็นบ้าน
ก็ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ที่บ้านมีห้องนอนมี
เตียงคือบ้านครูฟ้าผู้หญิงไม่รู้นะคะว่า
มี 1 ชั้น 2 ชั้นหรือเปล่าอันนี้ผู้หญิง
ไม่รู้อันนี้ผู้หญิงเขียนเองนะคะนักเรียน
ในค่ะแต่ว่ามี 1
มี 1 ชั้นเนาะไม่เป็นไรนะคะก็ถ้าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยนอนใช่ไหม
5  1 คืนนะคะตอนกลางคืนใช่ไหมตอนนี้ 7
โมงเช้าเนี่ยเป็นตอนกลางวันตาครูฟ้าได้
ตื่นมาทำงานเรียนหนังสือเสร็จแล้วตอนกลาง
คืน 2 ทุ่ม
ก็เป็นตอนกลางคืนครูฟ้าเนี่ยเข้านอนนอน
แล้ว
แต่สองทุ่มเนี่ย
ครูฟ้ายังไม่หลับใช่ไหมยังไม่
ยังไม่หลับ
นอน
ดูซีรีย์นอนหนาว
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนมีคำถามแล้วค่ะว่าที่บ้าน
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่มีผ้าห่มหรอ
ก็มีค่ะแต่ว่าหนาวนิดหน่อยนะคะ
ตอนนี้นะคะนักเรียนนักเรียนจะได้ยินคำว่า
หนาวหนาว
บ่อยๆเมื่อก่อนใช่ไหม 2,022 เนี่ยนัก
เรียนจะได้ยินจากครูหญิงครูฟ้าเนี่ยร้อน
ร้อน
ก็เปลี่ยนวางใช่ไหมครูฟังก็นอนอยู่อย่าง
นี้ค่ะกำลังนอนนอนเล่นโทรศัพท์แล้วก็ได้
ยินเสียง
เสียงเหมือนอะไรที่กำลังบิน
นกบิน
นก
นกก็บิน
แต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตัวเล็กๆไงถ้ามันจะได้ยิน
เสียงบินเนี่ยมันก็อาจจะ
แมคโดนัล
ใช่ไหมมีก้อนเมฆแล้วก็มีนกนกนกนก
เป็นแบบนี้อันแม็กโดโน
ไม่เหมือนกัน
โอเคค่ะ
ไม่ใช่เสียงนกบินค่ะมันใหญ่มากกว่านก
[เพลง]
ใหญ่มากกว่านก
นกไจแอนท์
เครื่องบินก็บินได้นะ
เฮลิคอปเตอร์หรอ
เฮลิคอปเตอร์อย่างนี้ใช่ไหมเฮลิคอปเตอร์
เป็นอย่างนี้หรอ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็มี
เฮลิคอปเตอร์
กำลังนอนเล่นโทรศัพท์อยู่แล้วก็ได้ยิน
เสียงเหมือนมีอะไรก็ไม่รู้บินอยู่บนบ้าน
ของครูฟ้าว่าเวลามีอะไรบินอยู่บนบ้าน
เนี่ยเราจะเราจะรู้สึกใช่ไหมคะแต่ว่ามัน
ไม่ได้บินผ่านบ้านครูฟ้าไปไงบินแล้วก็ลงๆ
ๆๆจอดที่บ้านครูฟ้าบ้านครูฟ้าไม่มีที่จอด
เฮลิคอปเตอร์
รู้เออแล้วกูฟ้าเนี่ยข้างหลังครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เป็นหน้าต่างใช่ไหมเนี่ยหน้าต่าง
ครูฟ้าก็แบบ
อะไรบ้านครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่มีที่จอด
เฮลิคอปเตอร์ใช่ไหมเวลามีที่จอด
เฮลิคอปเตอร์มันจะมีตัว S แล้วก็ลงจอดคุณ
ฟ้าก็
เสียงอะไรมีอะไรบินลงมาครูฟ้าก็เลยเปิด
หน้าต่างไปแล้วครูฟ้าก็เห็น
สิ่งนี้ค่ะ
ครูหญิง
อะไร
โคมไฟหรอคะ
โคมไฟ
โคมไฟก็ต้องเป็นอย่างนี้ไหมแล้วก็มีไฟถือ
จะเป็นโคมไฟอันนี้มันเป็นวงกลมเห็นไหม
แล้วก็มีรูอะไรตรงนี้มีแสงออกมาด้วย
ครูฟ้ารู้ไหมว่าอันนี้
คืออะไร
นี่มัน
UFO โอๆ
นะคะนักเรียนมันมีเพลง
มันมีเพลงอยู่ fo แล้วก็มีท่าเต้นแบบนี้
นะ
คะตอนนั้น
ถ้าสมมุติว่ามีญาณของ UFO แล้วก็นี่เป็น
บ้านครูฟ้า
[เพลง]
แล้วยาน UFO เนี่ยไม่รู้มาจากไหนนะคะแล้ว
ก็บินมาแล้วก็ลงจอดที่บ้านครูฟ้า
คำถามแรกเลยนะ
ครูฟ้ารู้สึกอะไรคะ
ตกใจ
หรือว่า
ดีใจได้เห็นยาน UFO ฟ้าจะรู้สึกว่า
หน้าครูฟ้าจะเป็นยังไง
อันนี้ก็คือหน้าครูฟ้านะคะนักเรียน
ทำไมตาครูฟ้าไม่เท่ากันน่ะ
ใช่ไหมคะ
งงอะไรอ่ะครูฟ้า
มาได้ยังไง
หรือว่า ET  Go  Home อะไรอย่างนี้หรือ
เปล่าใช่ไหมคะแต่ไม่ใช่ Hollywood ค่ะครู
ฟ้า
ยันต์
uso จริงๆ
UFO จริงๆ
ครูฟ้ารู้ไหมทำไมถึงคุยถึงบอกว่าเป็นยาน
uso จริงๆคือฟ้าไม่รู้ค่ะทำไมถึงเป็นยาน
ล่ะคะคุณหญิง
นี่ไงก็คือฟ้าเห็นไหมพอมันมีรูตรงนี้พอ
เขาใกล้ๆจะลงจอดมีแสงปุ๊บก็มีมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวเนี่ยลงมาอุ๊ยหน้าเหมือนครูฟ้าเลยอ่ะ
เห็นไหมก็มีมนุษย์ต่างดาวคนนี้ลงมา
จากยานอยู่foมนุษย์ต่างดาวหรือว่า
เอเลี่ยน
ทำไมถึงหน้าตาแบบนี้
เออนั่นสิทำไมหน้าไม่เหมือนเราเนาะ
[เพลง]
จมูกตาโตมากนะคะตา
โตมาก
ใช่ค่ะตาโตจมูกจมูกเล็กๆนะคะปากเล็กๆแล้ว
ก็มีมนุษย์ต่างดาวลงมาครูฟ้าเนี่ยเปิด
หน้าต่างแล้วก็เห็นมนุษย์ต่างดาว
คุณฟ้ารู้สึกอะไรคะตอนนั้นเห็นยาน UFO
เนี่ยครูฟ้าก็แบบ
อะไรแต่พอเห็นมนุษย์ต่างดาว
ครูเพราะเป็นยังไงคะ
ก็คิดว่า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ถ้าอยากรู้ไงครูฟ้าอยากเห็น UFO อยากเห็น
เอเลี่ยน
[เพลง]
อยากคุยถ้าอยากคุยครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าจะคุยอะไรอ่ะคุณฟ้าจะคุยอะไรกับ
มนุษย์ต่างดาวพูดอะไรกับมนุษย์ต่างดาว
สวัสดี
มนุษย์ต่างดาว
ครูฟ้าจะพูดจะพนมมือไหมสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนะคะแล้วก็ถามว่ามาทำอะไร
ครูฟ้าคิดว่ามนุษย์ต่างดาวฟังครูฟ้าเข้า
ใจไหมมนุษย์ต่างดาวไม่ได้เรียนภาษาไทยนะ
ครูฟ้าพูดสวัสดีมาทำอะไรครูฟ้าคิดว่าเขา
ฟังครูฟ้าเข้าใจไหม
ไม่เข้าใจ
ยังไม่ได้เรียนภาษาไทยที่ complainable
ไทยไง
อ๋อครูฟ้าก็จะหยิบโทรศัพท์ขึ้นมาแล้วครู
ฟ้าก็จะเปิด YouTube
YouTube ใช่ YouTube
Comment
เรียนภาษาไทยกับครูหญิงครูฟ้าค่ะ
ไม่ได้คุยไม่ได้เพราะมนุษย์ต่างดาวไม่
เข้าใจใช่ไหม
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
มนุษย์ต่างดาว
น่าจะพูดได้ไหม
ได้ค่ะ
ถ้าเขาฟ้าคุยกับเขาไม่เข้าใจพูดกับเขา
หรือว่าครูฟ้ามี
คำถามถามเขาแต่เขาไม่เข้าใจแล้วครูฟ้าจะ
ทำยังไงล่ะ
มนุษย์ต่างดาวอยู่ที่บ้านครูฟ้าแล้วอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าจะทำอะไรทำยังไงพาเขาไปไหนไหมครู
ฟ้าไม่เป็นไรค่ะเพราะครูฟ้าเป็นครูสอน
ภาษาไทยว่าจะมีเทคนิคคุยกับเขา
ก็ได้
คิดว่ามันโอเค
มันก็จะพาเขาไปกินส้มตำ
ถ้ามนุษย์ต่างดาวเนี่ยมาที่บ้านของครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าจะพาไปกินส้มตำเผ็ดๆเนี่ยนะคะครู
ฟ้าจะใส่พริกกี่เม็ดให้มนุษย์ต่างดาว
เนี่ยกินใส่พริกกี่เม็ด
30 เม็ด
ใส่พริก 30 เม็ดแล้วมนุษย์ต่างดาวเนี่ย
กินกินเผ็ดได้หรอ
คิดว่าอาจจะได้นะ
เพราะว่าบ้านของมนุษย์ต่างดาวใช่ไหม
มนุษย์ต่างดาวก็มีบ้านที่บ้านเนี่ยมนุษย์
อาจจะกินเผ็ดก็ได้นะคะ
พริกแบบปาปริก้า
เออใช่เนาะแล้วครูฟ้าจะทำอะไรอีกไหมคะถ้า
แบบอยู่ดีๆเนี่ยก็มีญาณของมนุษย์ต่างดาว
แล้วก็มีมนุษย์ต่างดาวเนี่ยมาที่บ้านของ
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าจะทำยังไงจะทำอะไรอีก
แบบอยู่ดีๆเราเจอมนุษย์ต่างดาวนะครูฟ้า
จะพาเขาไปถ่ายรูปนะคะหลายๆที่
ก็จะถ่ายรูป
ถ่ายรูป
พัทยาไม่ได้สิ
พาเขาไปทัวร์ออสเตรเลียไปดูจิงโจ้ไหม
เขาอาจจะไม่เคยเห็น
นักเรียนก็งงว่าครูหญิงมันคืออะไร
ก็ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยมีจิงโจ้มากๆใช่ไหมครู
หญิงก็เลยถามบอกว่าครูฟ้านี่จิงโจ้นะคะพา
มนุษย์ต่างดาวไปดูจิงโจ้ไหม
จะพาไปไหม
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าจะพามนุษย์ต่างดาวไปดูจิงโจ้
แล้วเขาจะให้มนุษย์ต่างดาวกับจิงโจ้ต่อย
กัน
เป็น Match เหรอคะมวยไทย
สีเวลาแจกชกมวยมันก็จะมีสีแดงใช่ไหมสีแดง
มนุษย์ต่างดาว
แล้วก็
สีน้ำเงิน
สีน้ำเงินจิงโจ้
สีน้ำเงินก็เป็นจิงโจ้แล้วครูฟ้าก็จะให้
มนุษย์ต่างดาวกับจิงโจ้ต่อยกันค่ะ
แล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่าใครจะชนะมนุษย์ต่างดาว
หรือ
จิงโจ้ผู้หญิงจะพยายามว่าจิงโจ้
คิดว่าใครจะชนะ
ครูฝ้ายคิดว่า
จิงโจ้ค่ะ
ทำไมอ่ะ
มนุษย์ต่างดาวมาจากที่อื่นนะเขาอาจจะมี
เทคโนโลยีก็ได้
แต่จิงโจ้แข็งแรง
หางแข็งแรง
แขนแข็งแรง
ก็เลยคิดว่าจิงโจ้ชนะแน่นอน
แล้วถ้ามนุษย์ต่างดาวเนี่ย
ที่เราคู่ฟ้าพาไปกินส้มตำพาไปเที่ยวพาไป
ดูจิงโจ้พาไปต่อยกับจิงโจ้แล้วมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวสนุกมากๆมีความสุขแล้วก็ชอบครูฟ้ามากๆ
แล้วมนุษย์ต่างดาวบอกว่าครูฟ้า
ให้ครูฟ้า
ขึ้น
uso แล้วก็ไปกับมนุษย์ต่างดาวครูฟ้าไป
ไหมถ้ามนุษย์ต่างดาวเนี่ยชวนครูฟ้าครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าอาจจะไม่ได้พูดก็ได้
ฮึบๆๆๆ
ทำท่าจะไหมอุ้ยอะไรเนี่ย
มาๆๆ
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าก็อยู่ที่นี่ใช่ไหม
แล้วตรงนี้ก็เป็นมนุษย์ต่างดาว
แล้วก็ให้ครูฟ้ากับมนุษย์ต่างดาวนะคะ
แล้วก็
คืนไปบน UFO แล้วก็นี่บ้านครูฟ้าใช่ไหม
อันนี้เป็นโรคใบมีออสเตรเลียประเทศไทย
อเมริกาแคนาดาแล้วก็ไม่รู้ไปดาวอะไร
ครูฟ้าไปกับมนุษย์ต่างดาวไหมคะ
หรือว่า
เอ้าทำไมอ่ะ
จะไปเห็นหรอเหมือนสตาร์วอร์ส
ทำไมไม่ไป
ฟ้าคิดว่าอาหารอร่อยไหม
คะว่าครูฟ้าไม่ไปเพราะคิดว่าดาวนี้เนี่ย
อาหารไม่โอเคแน่ๆ
ครูฟ้ารู้แล้วอาหารอร่อย
ก็เลยไปกับมนุษย์ต่างดาวค่ะใช่ไม่ไปค่ะ
ครูฟ้ารักอาหารในโลกนะคะ
ก็เลยไม่ไป
แล้วก็
แล้วถ้ามนุษย์ต่างดาวบอกถ้างั้นมนุษย์
ต่างดาวบอกโอเคฟ้าไม่ไปมนุษย์ต่างดาวอยู่
ที่บ้านกับครูฟ้าโอเคไหม
โอเค
โอเคหรอกูฟังไม่กลัวมนุษย์ต่างดาวข้าครู
ฟ้าหรอ
ไม่หรอกมั้ง
แล้วก็มีเตียงนอนเนี่ยนะ
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าหน่อยแล้วก็มนุษย์ต่างดาว
นอนด้วยกันเรียนด้วยกันเป็นเพื่อนกันโอเค
best  friend  Forever
be
ครูฟ้ากับมนุษย์ต่างดาว
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยถ้า 1 วันมีมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวมาที่บ้านของครูฟ้าครูบาก็โอเคนะไม่
กลัวพาไปเที่ยวไปกินอาหารอร่อยๆนะคะแล้ว
นักเรียนล่ะคะถ้า 1 วันมี
UFO มาที่บ้านของนักเรียนมีมนุษย์ต่าง
ดาวนักเรียนจะทำยังไงจะพาไปไหน comment
บอกเราได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยคิดว่า
ให้ครูฟ้าเขาไปคุยกับมนุษย์ต่างดาวแล้ว
กัน bff อยู่ที่นี่นักเรียนมองไม่เห็นนะ
คะใช่วันนี้เราสองคนไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกัน
ใหม่วีดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะ